les militants étaient chauffés à bloc et
ARS soir après la victoire sans
équivoque de Québec solidaire dans ce
comté historiquement libéral
la lutte s'annonçait série mais avec
plus de 44% des voix Guillaume
clicherart succède aisément à l'ex-chef
Dominique anglaise on s'attendait à un
résultat un peu plus serré la force de
cette victoire là nous surprend un peu
on l'apprend avec beaucoup de modestie
comme un encouragement pour le principal
intérêt c'est avocat en immigration
c'est un important changement qui
s'amorce le travail commence le travail
continue mais il commence aussi c'est un
nouveau chapitre pour moi que j'entame
mais vous pouvez être certain que je
vais toujours continuer à être une voix
forte pour l'inclusion le Parti libéral
du Québec a donc été chassé de Saint
Henri Sainte-Anne désormais un ancien
bastion rouge c'est un résultat pour
nous qui est un échec c'est un échec là
on va pas se le cacher et collectivement
les militants également on doit se poser
les questions quand même par célébrale
du Québec peut reconnecter avec la
population le vote libéral s'était fondé
Québec Solidaire a remis une campagne
qui s'est caractérisée entre par des
pamphlets unilingue en anglais la
population qui souhaitait visiblement
renverser la tendance comment témoignent
aussi le taux de participation à cette
élection partielle qui a mobilisé plus
de 30% des citoyens
je suis très content parce que ça
faisait du bien de changer un petit peu
d'air là
mais pour les fidèles et lecteurs du
Parti libéral comme celui-ci c'est une
cuisante des fêtes qu'on s'explique mal
c'est catastrophique que je me demande
comment est-ce que c'est parti qui avait
les pieds des racines dans ce secteur il
a lamentablement échoué Guillaume
clicherie Var qui se présentait pour la
deuxième fois à remporté ce match
revanche il amorce son mandat avec une
ultime priorité en tête le logement ici
aimer le mieux Radio-Canada Montréal
[Applaudissements]